people have been so warped by this
nonsense they've been so radicalized
that even now on the sports channel
espn max kellerman not that i watch espn
a whole lot and i certainly don't know
that they've gone total lib but
max kellerman comes out he says the
protests are peaceful
ignore what you're seeing it's just like
every other guy on cnn and msnbc
standing in front of burning police
headquarters and they say
no mostly peaceful little fiery but
mostly peaceful he goes out he says look
they're mostly peaceful and whenever
there is violence
it's extreme right-wing agitators
a few of the things he said when he
talks about like
black lives matter 93 of the protests
are peaceful
the vast overwhelming majority are
peaceful and by the way the seven
percent that are not
they have a very broad definition of
what's not quote unquote peaceful like
for example if you block traffic or
something like that or if you respond to
police
provocation and even then a big
percentage of that
which we that that wasn't peaceful is
actually outside
agitators extremist right-wing agitators
posing
as protesters in order to make the
protests look bad that's the first thing
wow brilliant analysis for mr kellerman
the protests are totally peaceful but
actually
they're violent but the violence is
caused by the cops but no actually the
violence is caused by
right-wing agitators that we never seem
to find anywhere they're not but they're
there
they just they hide themselves and how
do they hide them they they dress up
like left-wing agitators yeah yeah
that's the ticket
yeah and then they talk like left-wing
agitators yeah and they target
all of the things that the left-wing
agitators want to destroy like the
police stations
yeah yeah that's it right wing agitators
are tearing down statues of george
washington and thomas jefferson
and looting businesses and stealing nike
shoes and gucci bags
and torching police stations because
right-wing agitators
okay not very convincing
by the way that is obviously a
conspiracy theory right i know the left
always likes to say that
anytime conservatives breathe too
heavily we're engaging in a conspiracy
theory you know anytime
anything comes out of our mouths it's a
conspiracy theory
but i'll give you an example the left
says that there's this crazy right-wing
conspiracy theory that there's an elite
pedophile ring that involves heads of
state and royalty
and you know prime ministers and things
like that
so we say well what about jeffrey
epstein
and you know prince andrew and bill
clinton was flying all around there and
he had this bill clinton had this kind
of
nice intimate dinner with gillane
maxwell that news just broke and that
was pretty recent i was in like 2014
and you've got a lot of other i don't
know it doesn't seem like a conspiracy
theory and then the guy
when they finally arrest him he
mysteriously dies in jail and they say
it's a suicide even though
apparently none of the cameras worked
and all the guards went away you know it
just seems like
it's not a conspiracy theory that's a
conspiracy
right that's that's the that's the
prominent right-wing example of a
conspiracy theory
here's here's an example of a totally
mainstream left-wing story so main
stream it's on the sports channel
all the left-wing agitators are secretly
white right-wing agitators
yeah all the guys who say they're
left-wing and and
dress up like left-wingers and torch
left-wing targets
the targets of left-wingers they're
secretly right-wingers and they're just
doing it ironically or something right
which is the conspiracy theory obviously
obviously the latter i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts